hey there everybody welcome to
metaphysical milkshake i'm rayne wilson
and i'm reza aslan hi rayne how you
doing uh you know i'm doing okay
i'm doing all right i'm hanging in there
that's good but i have something on my
mind that i wanted to talk to you about
hit me i was thinking about growing up
in the 70s and 80s like what did we
really deal with what were
the pressures on us as children
in that generation well i'm much younger
than
you obviously so i don't really remember
this here we go
um yeah but i do remember i remember the
80s i remember like in elementary school
um being like legitimately stressed out
about nuclear war because
it would come up all the time at school
like remember they would be like hey
it's friday we're going to practice for
for nuclear fallout everybody under your
desk do you remember that movie with
like hal
holbrook about like the end of the world
and
i do remember that the nuclear threat
and nuclear winter and stuff that was
pretty scary
it was pretty daunting i remember
thinking about it all the time
yeah that was a big stress yeah in the
70s we had some long gas
lines um there was the iranian hostage
crisis
something you know a little bit about
why do you have to bring that up all the
[ __ ] time all right i'm sorry
i am sorry and you know for you 80s kids
there were the lat there was the latch
key kid
syndrome you know just being uh boohoo
we had a key around our neck and we went
in and our parents were at work and we
just watched
cartoons and we ate froot loops it was
great and like oh that was so traumatic
i loved that what did you watch it was
more like coco pebbles and bugs bunny
for me
okay yeah fruit loops hr puff and stuff
that explains
so much so we had our trauma
uh during that time but man it's nothing
compared to kids these days
nothing it's not even in the same
ballpark i mean i look at these these
kids today and the things that they deal
with
these kids today with their school
shootings and their global pandemics
yeah there's yeah global pandemics you
can die going to school and by the way
if you manage to survive
either death at school or a global
pandemic you're going to die because the
planet's dying anyway
like i i mean i'm just so glad i'm not a
child right now i really
am so so glad plus all the race
stuff that is it's good it's coming to
light but man it's traumatizing too
and um and especially these children who
come from diverse and more marginalized
communities i mean
oh yeah they have it so much so much
worse
oh so much worse i i just think about i
know that
you hate it when i talk about politics
i'm not going to talk about politics but
i will say that
i remember thinking a lot about the way
that my boys were dealing with
you know the the trump years and this
notion that kind of
you know they would say it in in the
most matter-of-fact way
like in the most matter-of-fact way they
would talk about how
um you know uh the president of the
united states
thinks of you know them as an enemy
like and you know that they're they're
very that their very
existence is thought of as a threat to
like
large swaths of this country and just a
matter of factness with the way that we
talk about it would start to freak me
out like what
what is this doing to their brains what
is this doing to their mental health
like that this is the world that they
live in
absolutely i remember my teenage son
asking me about
uh wait why are there children in cages
at the border
like oh that's a tough one to explain to
a to a to a 12 year old 13 year old
yeah i mean are the kids all right
that's the question
for the pod today are the kids all right
spoiler alert no no they're not they're
not all right actually
no they're not okay welcome to
metaphysical milkshake the show where we
go deep
we get weird and we search for the
meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
um but these are some very real concerns
and it's good
it's a good thing reza we've got the
brilliant dr alfie breeland noble
here with us today to help answer this
incredibly concerning question
yeah is there just too much out there is
there just too much [ __ ] going on in the
world right now and is it traumatizing
them in some kind of
you know deeply personal way that we're
all gonna pay the price for
you know in the in the next few years dr
alfie
fortunately is an internationally
recognized scientist author and media
contributor
she's the founder of the acoma project
that's a non-profit organization um that
specializes
in the mental health of young people
she's very sought after mental health
expert who's currently hosting season
two of her video podcast
couched in color with dr alfie yep she's
uh
regularly appears on cnn i've heard of
that
network nbc uh npr
she works you know regularly with uh
duke university in georgetown and she's
the author
of a book it's called community mental
health engagement with
racially diverse populations we're gonna
have to give her some advice on how to
title a book
that's a little wordy but welcome to the
show dr alfie
thank you for having me i'm so excited
to be here you have no idea
we're super excited to have you and i
understand you're a little bit of an
office fan
too oh see now i was trying not to go
there
jesus christ i was trying like we i was
literally i was trying to be good
because
you have a huge career do we have to do
this
with every guest do we have to begin by
forcing them
to talk about the objectives
i get to say dwight schrute you get to
as many times as you like listen
listen russell we don't do this every
time it just happens
that our guest uh one of the top mental
health
specialists in the country happens to be
a huge
office dwight street rayne wilson fan
and that that must be acknowledged come
on she wrote her dissertation on you
didn't she
isn't that someone someday will write a
dissertation
on mental health in the office workplace
of dunder mifflin
oh my yes all the characters i'm gonna
diagnose each one of them that's a good
idea that's a book
that's a book actually that is a book
that would sell a lot of copies honestly
with all the office fans out there
anyhow we dig into mental illness a lot
on this show it's a cause that i'm
extremely passionate about it's
something i know something about because
i have
suffered from it in various facets which
we've certainly discussed
but let's set the stage for what we're
going to be talking about today
so 50 of all lifetime mental illnesses
develop
by age 14. 75
developed by age 24. suicide is the
second leading cause of death
among people aged 10 to 34 in the united
states that's insane
that's just i mean what what staggering
still it makes you want to cry it makes
me want to cry it's so sad that people
don't feel like they have any other way
out it's just it's bad
it is it is the overall suicide rate in
the united states has increased by 35
since 1999. that you know
yeah i'm i'm an old geezer but that's
not that long that's when i moved to la
1999 like
it's gone up by over a third in that
amount of time
yep and in september of 2020 over half
of 11 to 17 year olds reported
having thoughts of suicide or self-harm
and
uh and then we have the fact that people
are not getting the help they need 60
of youth with major depression did not
receive any mental health treatment
and this is in 2017 2018
even in states with the greatest access
38 percent
not receiving the mental health services
that they need
and among youth with severe depression
only a quarter of them are receiving
consistent
treatment the list goes on and on
there's so many more statistics i could
rattle off
i'm sure you're familiar with all of
these dr alfie but you are on the front
lines literally on the front lines
dealing with kids working with kids
especially kids of color
um so tell us give us your assessment
what the hell is happening
what is happening to our kids are the
kids all right no the
clearly the answer is no the kids are
not all right that's right reza they're
they're not all right i
it's a lot of things i think it at this
point in time you have this
awful perfect storm of covert 19
kids being stuck in the house like you
just think about we
all of the awful shootings we've seen
in the last couple of weeks um it's just
it's just a lot and so you almost can't
look away
um so that's a big part of it i think is
that you have these rising rates
in part in the last year because people
couldn't look away
you are stuck in the house people are
like sort of fixated on their devices
whatever those devices are
and they're just not in a place where
they can turn away from these awful
things that we're seeing that's a part
of it but that's new
when you think more long term going back
to like you said 99 99 was a big
that was the year my big birthday you
turned 18
yeah right um so just thinking about
going back that
far i think about how
few of our young people are prepared and
given coping skills
right and so they don't have the coping
skills to help them man many don't have
the coping skills to help them manage
all of the deluge of things that are
coming at them on top of that
you have all this new access to
information so you have this thing where
these young people
have a lot of new information they are
bombarded with a lot of
new ideas and i don't know just
information coming at them
but what they don't have is a way to
process the new information that's
coming their way
you said so many interesting things
there but
the thing that like caught my attention
was that obviously like so much of
you know the situation that young people
are are dealing with when it comes to
mental health right now has to do with
the world that they're living in i mean
look around you we're dealing with you
know total climate
collapse we're dealing with racial
violence on the streets we're dealing
with a global pandemic and everything
that's involved
with that but you know earlier on rayne
and i were talking
about the fact that when we were kids
you know there was
a lot of social trauma i mean for me in
the 80s growing up for
rain in the 40s growing up
50s 50s my mistake like i
i clearly remember i was just talking
about this i clearly remember
like the duck and cover drills for you
know in case of nuclear annihilation
yep so didn't we have a lot of crazy
things that we were dealing with
too uh you know i mean is it worse now
and we would have totally survived by
the way nuclear bomb
under the school desk oh absolutely we
would have been fine
we would have been fine why else would
we have practiced getting under the
school desk if it wasn't
going to save us from nuclear
annihilation well there you go
duh wait hold on hold on are you saying
our teachers were not telling the truth
but you hear what i'm saying right it's
like i don't want to in any way diminish
the fact that the
world is [ __ ] right now but it seemed
fairly [ __ ] in the 80s
it was but you got to think that it was
it was a little different for us because
we were encouraged to cope with more
things at an earlier age
number one this is my opinion number two
which is the only thing that matters
anyway
number two it is you know
we didn't have we weren't bombarded we
didn't have 24-hour cable news
in the 80s not that i recall no so you
had you had 30 minutes
in the afternoon at 6 o'clock you had 30
minutes at 11 o'clock
and that was it you know what i'm saying
so like this stuff when you are it's
just constantly coming at you
we didn't necessarily now let's think
about context in the united states let's
talk about how often we talked about
what was happening
in other parts of the world we didn't
talk about that stuff unless it was
something like
ginormous that had that was tangentially
related to the united states but if it
wasn't
we didn't talk about that so or you were
studying something from history
i think what's a little bit different
now is kids
they're seeing everything happening in
real time
right like when my kids were little my
kids were 16 and 14
and huge office fans by the way i just
had to say
oh jesus again right they got me into it
you know my kids would often bring
things to me i remember
you know it's not the only time there
was a huge syrian conflict and y'all
remember that picture of the little boy
who's just sitting and crying the first
person who brought that to my attention
was my daughter and she was a little
she was an elementary school kid and she
had a device
and she saw it on the device she was
like and she was boohoo and crying
right we we didn't grow up like that so
i think there were things but i don't
think we had anywhere near the volume
that our young people deal with now
and we also had to figure out a lot more
stuff on our own at an earlier age right
so we were the one the generation of
sticks and stones may break my bones and
like you didn't go tell when somebody
was bullying you you just sort of dealt
with it
we don't ask kids to do things like that
now and you know some of that's good
but it's just they're just different
circumstances for us
than there are for these kids right now
so to put words in your mouth
essentially what you seem to be saying
is it's not
that the world is so much worse now
than it was when we were kids although
maybe it is
uh it's that it's unavoidable it's that
the [ __ ] is unavoidable
it's in your face when we were kids you
could choose to ignore it
you know you don't you can get under the
desk right you could get under the desk
and everything was fine but now there is
no desk
to torture the metaphor right now it's
like there's no way that you can avoid
um the images of racial violence on the
street was there racial violence in the
60s and 70s
yeah but now it's unavoidable it's in
your face it's
everywhere but isn't that kind of a good
thing though sorry to jump in
res but i was just in my
lilly white privileged bubble of
suburban seattle
i had no idea cops were doing this to
black people
you know right and left day and night i
just my parents
didn't do a very good job of educating
me but it wasn't on the news it wasn't
there wasn't a twitter feed to look at
um to to to find this out
so so this is this is good right we're
we're being you know this white
privilege bubbles being popped but
information overload and feeling like
these problems are unsolvable
and that and uh and that the violence
is it's got to be traumatic to just be
experiencing this
you know school shootings and um and
police brutality
and uh other kind of abject
racism um how do
we find the balance between the good and
bad of this i mean i think
for me what i'm learning and what i've
learned to do over the years
is how to take things and understand
that i can be in two places at once
i can be a person who comes from a group
that experiences marginalization but i'm
also a person with privilege
right and so when i look at it like that
it helps me to not be stuck
in all of the awful things that happen
to black people all the time because
then i think about
what about all the awful things that are
happening to latinx kids right kids in
cages well what about all the awful
things happening to
it's not a race but you know a religious
group like people who are muslim
what about all the you know with
islamophobia what about all the awful
things that happened to
recently asian americans and asian
people
um or native american people and so for
me not to mention
these overarching identities of like
uh whether or not you have a disability
and or whether or not you're queer
so when i think about all of those you
know and i don't know if it's perverse
or not but in a weird way it gives me
comfort because i know i'm not alone
right there's always someone else out
there who is experiencing something
who's struggling
who has a history where their people or
their cultural group
have had these really awful things
happen to them so in that sense
i don't feel so alone i feel seen and i
feel like other people
i see other people and they can see me
in my pain
um so
that helps me find balance the other
thing is i have to actively
practice things to help me find balance
meaning i'm an avid i really believe in
meditation
i just need to clear my head right and a
different kind of meditation
so i have to engage in practices that
help me find
balance and then doing this kind of work
helps me find balance because this is my
purpose i really do feel like this is my
purpose on this planet is to support
people and help them with them with
their mental health and with emotional
well-being
i mean the final thing i have to add is
i heard jake tapper say earlier today
that it's not
so much this to your point reza it's not
so much that there's more racism sexism
homophobia blah blah blah i'm putting
words in your mouth
it's that it's more visible so it's not
that there's more of it
it's just that there are more people out
there with cameras and devices filming
it so more of us can see it it's on the
news 24 7. so in that sense again
i also am mindful that that
society hasn't changed that much in
terms of how we persecute people who
gets persecuted what's changed is that
more of the persecuted people
have a voice yeah yeah um and that's the
good side of devices they can
you know they can share with the world
and express themselves yeah
rain i'm going to be a little bit uh
vulnerable here for a second
okay i'm having um some problems with uh
my weight i just i feel like this
pandemic i've just been yeah
i haven't been exercising i've been
feeling good about myself i haven't been
eating well yeah so what are you gonna
do about that i'm going to try noon
how convenient because they're a sponsor
of our show convene exactly
noom uses a psychology-based approach to
find a healthier balance that's
moldable to your life and as a result it
becomes more sustainable
folks listen you don't need rules to
lose weight just the knowledge and
wisdom to help you build smarter more
sustainable habits
newm's cognitive behavioral approach
helps you unlearn bad habits and better
understand your relationship with food
that's what it's all about it's your
relationship with food that's it right
one size does not fit all just choose
your goals
noon will personalize a weight loss
program to you 80
of newm users finish the program that's
that's that's impressive that's a lot
over 60 have stuck with their goals for
at least a year
i don't need a year just a few months
that's all you need with noom taking
care of your health is empowering
instead of stress inducing no need to
fear ruining the whole program or the
day off here or there
no we'll help you get back on track all
you need is a daily 10-minute check-in
how hard is that i could do that no
grueling early mornings or huge
chunks out of your day so start building
better habits
for healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial
at noom.com milkshake that's
n-o-o-m dot com slash
milkshake you know rain remember when we
were kids and we would wake up early in
the morning
saturday morning grab a bowl of cocoa
puffs
you make it sound like we lived in the
same cul-de-sac and mom would be like
don't eat too many cocoa puffs
cereal was like one of the best parts of
being a kid that didn't have no
responsibility yes
i would plow through boxes of cereal
they weren't just like for breakfast it
was just
any time of day i would say like between
9 and 11
i mostly was made of cereal
but of course i had to give it up
because obviously it's all full of sugar
and junk and all that stuff that you
shouldn't eat but guess what what
now there's magic spoon magic spoon has
zero grams of sugar
amazing 13 to 14 grams of protein yes
and
only about four net grams of carbs in
each serving so
that's like 140 calories per serving
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb
i don't know how they do this gmo free
so go to
magicspoon.com milkshake to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
milkshake easy to remember
milkshake at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money
no questions asked remember get your
next delicious bowl
of guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
milkshake
don't forget to use the code milkshake
milkshake if you want to save five
dollars that's how you do it thank you
magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
i think you're right i think that a a
large part of
why it is that this generation is
struggling
with mental health in response to the
trauma
of you know the world that we live in
has as much to do with the fact that
it's that trauma is unavoidable and you
can't ignore it
because it's everywhere as it is with
the fact that maybe the trauma is
getting worse there is one very unique
factor though that we can't ignore
when it comes to any conversation about
the mental health particularly
of young people and that is this [ __ ]
pandemic
you know which uh i mean 63
of 18 to 24 year olds reported symptoms
of anxiety and depression during the
covid lockdown a quarter reported
increased substance abuse a quarter
reported a serious consideration of
suicide
you know i mean it's been kind of uh the
the quarantine's been a little bit
annoying for me but i've also
got to hang out with my family and and
read and write and that's been great and
you know rayne has a personal zoo that
he has to upkeep that takes up a lot of
his his quarantine time
uh i'm gonna put you in my personal zoo
but you know i think about my nephew who
was always kind of struggling with
you know social um uh
what's it called social anxiety and and
you know was a guy who kind of spent a
lot of his life
online in video game world anyway
and then he was told for 16 months not
to leave his house
and so i you know i love
i love him and i'm and i i'm almost
certain that he doesn't even know i have
a podcast and so isn't listening to this
because it's not a video game
but he is i mean i am scared to death
for
him now like i don't think he actually
leaves his room
anymore i mean his mental health is at
the point where
you know i don't even i don't even know
how to to make any kind of eye contact
with him any longer and he's i think one
of
hundreds of thousands of kids for whom
kovid has
taken what was already a problem we've
already talked about it was already a
problem and just
you know threw them down a well
i don't know i don't even have a
question that was it what what does
covid do to all of this
yeah again it comes back to this idea of
at what point do we encourage our loved
ones
or sort of grab our loved ones and say
to them
i want to support you and help you in
this and being stuck in the house
and like just sort of closing in on
yourself is not helping you
um and i don't know how often and i'm
not speaking to either one of you
specifically i just i hear a lot of
people
ask this question i don't know to what
extent a lot of us
know that it's important for us to go do
that for our loved ones i mean this is
what i do so i know it's important to
try to find that balance
but for so many of us it's just kind of
like well they're quiet they're fine
leave them alone you know let them be
there and i think for people who are
experiencing it
people who do have social anxiety people
who don't want to come out of the house
people who are agoraphobic like all
those kinds of folks i think
it is really this idea of
how do we sort of reach in and grab them
and
try to pull them out in a way that's
comfortable for them so it's really not
go
grab and say come on let's go have this
party like we're going to be socially
this they don't want to do that
but how do we engage them in a way that
supports them and helps them without
overwhelming them so i don't know
there's no real answer for it but
i do feel like it's an issue for a lot
of people going back to that idea of
loneliness some of it is us
communicating with each other and
teaching each other and helping each
other
learn how to be a little less lonely and
it takes
effort to me that's the most important
thing we can't be passive
and get through loneliness we have to be
active
but people have to know how to be active
to help them with that loneliness and
isolate isolation
and sometimes when you're lonely and
isolated and feeling
anxious and depressed being active
in any capacity it seems insurmountable
it really does and in those instances
where i
ask people to start is i just ask them
to think about
where do you want to be right and even
that's hard having the energy right
because i
know what it's like to go through
depression um and i'm a person who
manages anxiety so that the anxiety
doesn't manage me so i try to be really
open about that um but
brain i i think your point is well taken
i just
worry and get fearful about allowing
our loved ones to be stuck there
right to like we like we want to i don't
know even if all we're doing is just
saying i'm here
when you're ready i know you don't feel
like it today but maybe tomorrow maybe
in an hour i'm not going to bug you but
i just want you i want to keep telling
you that i am here so when you have
enough energy
to reach out to me and just let me know
i don't know
if i can sit and listen to you or cry
with you or whatever
i want you to know that i'm available
right so that can be a text
that can be face time that can be just
something to let the person know because
to your point when we feel that
we don't have energy it's hard to have a
positive outlook on life it's hard to
see that there are people who care
and so we just keep turning inward um
and as long as you're hearing someone
say regularly
periodically i love you i want to be
here for you
you don't have to do anything with that
information now i just want you to hear
it
i know in times when i've struggled
like my mom she's deceased but she would
just say that she would always say well
alfie there's nothing you could do baby
that would make me stop loving you and
i'm always going to be here if you need
to call me
2 a.m sweetheart call me it makes me
emotional thinking about
it oh you know i might not want to call
her yes it was just
i just knew she was there so when i felt
better i could call her at 2am and often
i did
dr alfie your area of expertise is
mental health in youth
of color and this is not a story you
hear about very much it's not in
every episode of as it's not in every
issue of psychology today
but as bad as things are for youth in
general
uh in this mental health epidemic during
this pandemic
it's way way worse for youth and color
can you speak to that
the disparities are more in who has
access to mental health care and what
kind of care do they get when they go in
so you would think
with the racial trauma and some of the
other you know
intersectional identity issues faced by
kids of color
that they would have far worse rates of
depression anxiety
maybe even um we call trauma exposure
related to depression and anxiety
uh but what you find in the
epidemiological research that's my one
big word i'm using today
is that those aren't really where you
see the the biggest differences where
you see the
in terms of the prevalence right so what
are the rates of depression among
kids across the board is somewhere
between like eight and twelve percent
now it's way higher since the pandemic
started
but when you look at anxiety 15 to 20
maybe 25
depending on who you ask um exposure to
trauma
you do see difference in terms of who's
exposed but then who's diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder and those
kinds of things
again you don't really see these these
huge differences
so the issue becomes
understanding and unpacking that why is
that the case i would argue part of
that's the case because we don't measure
effectively
i don't know that we know exactly what
depression looks like this is
probably a little out there but i don't
know that we know exactly what
depression looks like
across all these groups of kids because
kids are bringing different
parts of themselves into the world and
they're showing
up in ways that we don't always know how
to label correctly so one quick example
is
you take two kids you take a black kid
the kid can be black latinx they just
present to the world as black they take
one kid
they have the same symptoms um sadness
irritability
fatigue um
crying all the time that kind of thing
if you put both of those kids in front
of a mental health professional the same
mental health professional
they're more likely to diagnose that
black child with a disruptive behavior
problem right conduct disorder
oppositional defiant like they don't
listen we used to call them bad kids
back in the day but you don't call kids
bad you call behavior bad
kids are not bad inherently um and the
white child will be diagnosed with a
depressive disorder
so it's what are people paying attention
to what they're paying attention to
probably is the irritability in that
black child
and the sadness in the white child even
though what they're presenting with is
the same set of symptoms
so i think that's a part of it so when
you're treating
what are you treating you're treating
irritability in that black kid
you're treating sadness in the white
child but really you should be treating
the sadness in both of them
so i think that's a part of how we
measure i don't think we really know
because we don't measure well and then
one other thing i'll say is
part of what drives these disparities is
the personalized stigma right so
how are people going to receive me if i
show up
with this thing called mental illness
and the best succinct story i can tell
you about that
is years ago when i was doing research i
used to be a psychiatric professor at
duke
and we were doing some some research
down in durham north carolina and i had
a mom say to me i've never forgotten it
she had was recently like homeless she
had recently
uh you know begun re-entry from being
incarcerated and she had i don't know
four or five children she was wearing on
her own and she said dr alfie look
i'm already black i'm already a woman
i don't also need to be crazy and that's
sort of the right that's the idea it's
like i have these labels
already that marginalize me if you stick
crazy which i thought my kids would
never say that if you stick a mental
illness label on top of that you are
like really like sending me to the
hinterlands
and i don't want to be out there i want
to be here with everybody else so i
think those are some of the things that
drive
these disparities this is a great
question so it's it's like it's not so
much that
you know they have different brains or
different mental health issues
and oftentimes it's not even so much
that they are dealing
with necessarily different traumas
it's that on the one hand
white kids are diagnosed differently
than kids of color so like in a white
kid what what comes across
as depression comes across you know with
a black kid as just
being a bad kid being being you know
having trouble
um that's fine and then on the other
side of it too is the people who are
doing the the diagnoses right i mean we
just discovered this like
four percent of psychologists today are
black
four percent you want a four percent
they don't pay me like i'm the four
percent but i'm the four percent we just
leave it like that
look i know a lot of you guys out there
are carrying credit balances
month after month it can sometimes feel
like you're in this never-ending cycle
of debt
yes that's right so upstart uh can help
you make
that final payment so you get ahead
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt
with a personal loan all online so
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest
debt some of these credit cards i mean
the interest rates 25 27 percent crazy
or whether you use it to fund personal
expenses over a half a million people
have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment upstart knows you
more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit that's right and you know unlike
other lenders upstart considers your
income and current employment
to find you a smarter rate for your loan
that's right all it takes is a five
minute online rate check you can see
your rate up front for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after two thousand loans
fifty thousand dollars that's what
that's like couch change for you
well that's true find out how upstart
can lower your monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com
milkshake that's upstart.com milkshake
don't forget to use our url to let them
know that we sent you
milkshake milkshake milkshake loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan
application so go to upstart.com
milkshake
here's the thing conversations like this
always end with
man that's man this is really bad it
sucks
this is terrible so tell us dr alfie
what can we do
and then you tell us well we should do
this and we should do this and we should
do this and we say
yes indeed thank you we should increase
social programs and we should
decrease the stigma and we should get
people into greater
equity in the way that we deal with and
we need more education for
which of course is all true yeah that's
all true of course of course
is how most conversations go yeah let's
do all that i guess the larger issue
here is that you know we're talking
about
by the way not just literally the future
because i believe i don't know about you
reign but i believe the children are our
future
sing it i believe the children are our
future
teach them well and let them oh you can
see where they just threw up in my mouth
thank you for that
uh back to talking about a very serious
topic the mental health of our
children rain the future of our children
i believe the children are our future is
the lyric
thank you whitney houston and by the way
you know we're talking about children of
color
they're literally our future i mean we
are we are rapidly increasingly
rapid demographic changes in this
country so we're not talking about
you know just white kids we're talking
very specifically children of color
are literally the future and
what they're bringing to the future with
them are these
profound mental health issues and
traumas
so i guess my question isn't like what
do we do about it
my question is is what the what the [ __ ]
kind of civilization
are we looking at here you know in the
future that is going to be run by people
who are dealing with these
profound mental health issues in a way
that we
did not so when we get to talking about
the future i always try to come back to
because i meditate
i tell my patients all the time i tell
my best friends my best girlfriends
there's like four of us who called a
pretty rough rider crew that's my girls
anyway so what i say to them
is if you think too far ahead
it makes you worry because you don't
know what's coming if you think too far
going backwards
it makes you worry because you want to
fix stuff that maybe you got wrong
if you stay focused in the present
that's where you can maybe create change
in action because you're right here in
the moment you're not thinking about
this stuff that's coming that you can't
control that stuff that's behind this
you can't change
so that help gives me peace but that
wasn't a question so the question is
like if you
think about our young people and they
are our future and what are they
carrying
with them into the future i think we
also have to think about
what resources and skills and tools
do they already have and that's the part
that gives me a little more hope because
you would think
when you particularly look at kids of
color you think about all the
racial traumas or kids who are coming
from immigrant families who can be of
any race
you know the trauma of some of their
families through immigration that's
passed down right intergenerational
trauma or the kids themselves i think
about all these children coming
you know from central and south america
by themselves and what they must have
endured
you know to get to the united states i
also think about the resilience
that is inherent in people right and i
you know we do talk about i don't want
to make it like pollyanna they said oh
yeah kids are resilient they're going to
be fine i don't mean it in that way
but i do notice and see that there's so
many young people who probably could be
doing
so much worse and that's the thing that
gives me hope
and so my my thinking is if we can
learn from young people what makes them
take what makes them resilient what
helps them keep going
those are the things that i think we
want to start to build up but we're
building it from a place where we're
looking at what's helpful
for everybody because the history of my
field
if you only look at one group of people
right i say it's monochromatic and we
say okay that applies to everybody but
that's not true
so what we want to do is look at what
are these great things that come from
all these different groups whether
you're queer whether you're
black or latinx or asian or native right
whether you're middle eastern one of my
former research assistants she was one
of the best i ever had her family is
from lebanon
there's so many things that i learned
from her right about what it meant to
grow up as
lebanese both in lebanon and in the
states and many other places around the
world that i feel like
we're just life lessons for me as a
grown woman so
what can we learn from our young people
of all backgrounds and then how do we
put all that stuff together
so to feed it back to all of our kids so
that they're coming into the future
with a stronger sense of self with
better tools and with better ability to
care for their own mental health
on that line something you said uh
reminded me of one of my favorite quotes
which is from khalil gibran out of
suffering have emerged the strongest
souls
the most massive characters are seared
with scars
and that does give me hope that perhaps
this generation
that um has and is undergoing tremendous
suffering
and is seared with scars are going to be
the most massive
characters with the strongest souls and
they're the ones
kids i hope you can eventually be all
right and lead us
out of this so i
here's i have a personal question dr
alfie um
which is what does it do to your mental
health
to have to talk about this stuff all the
time like i mean
it's only been like 45 minutes and i'm
depressed
you know what i mean like what yeah how
do you handle
this all right so i'm not saying this to
flatter either one of you gentlemen but
i do want you to so when i get to the
end like oh she's just trying to be nice
right the day started where i was
actually yesterday i just i just didn't
feel right i felt uneasy i felt
like off center and i wasn't sure what
it was and i was meditating and i went
out i like to do nature walks i was out
nature walking with my dog and it just
i felt myself getting more and more
agitated and i just i was struggling and
it's all the weight and then it hit me
at night before i went to bed when i
stayed up too late
trying to you know like is the anxiety
i'll tell you if you don't know
if you're anxious the anxiety gets
really bad when everything gets quiet
so at night everybody sleep you i'm up
and i'm just like uh
so i'm listing the podcast i have no
business listening to because it's
making it worse
um but that was the night the next
morning
today i got up i went out and i lit i
really sat and meditated and i like to
sit by water
while i'm a pisces water is my thing um
and listen to the water
and then i noticed my spirit started to
lift a little bit and then
i encountered a couple people who were
really nice and said hello
and one stop and talk about how cute the
dog was all that stuff and i felt it
starting to
tick up by the time i got to
us recording now i had three or four
opportunities to have similar
conversations about mental health
in diverse populations about all of us
right marginalized people
people with privilege all of that and it
reminded me
that this is my purpose on the planet
and so the flattering thing i'm going to
say is i get to
end my day talking to
rayne wilson and dr reza like
that's what gives me it makes me want to
cry because
the fact that the two of you would pay
attention to someone like me and what i
do
given where i started my career when
people didn't even want to have this
conversation one of you said earlier
like this is not stuff we see in
psychology today
people didn't even want to have this
conversation with me when i started my
career
20-something years ago um so
that's what gives me hope it is knowing
that there are people out there who care
like the two of you
with the huge platform that you have and
it is being honest with myself
when it gets to be too heavy and and
giving myself permission to
stop look around
think and just remember that this is
some heavy [ __ ]
and sometimes i just gotta sit with the
[ __ ] and let it be heavy
until it lifts so that's what i was
saying well dr alfie
brellan noble this has been so
fascinating and exhilarating and
a little bit anxiety-making but also uh
positive uh and we can talk much longer
but
unfortunately it's time for the
lightning round
uh this is the time when we just ask you
uh a few of life's big questions
and you just kind of give us the first
uh thing that comes to your mind dr
alfie when do you feel most connected
with the universe
sitting in front of a body of water what
is a book that changed your life
the secret oh interesting
what is something that no one or very
few people
know about you one day i want to be a
surf pro
i love that absolutely we got to talk
further about i would come cheer you on
what's one emotion that you wish you
could control better anxiety
well that's not an emotion if hollywood
was making a biopic about your life what
would it be called
and who would play you uh first of all
angela bassett
yeah would play me oh my god i'm
obsessed with her too
anyway and it would be called
embrace encourage enlighten
the alfie breeland noble story what was
the happiest day of your life
having both of my kids so two days
two days okay but you're gonna have to
pick one of them so which kid do you
like better
oh okay okay the day my husband proposed
to me
uh what is one tip you can give parents
that would
by the way we are both parents that
would help with their children's
happiness
be honest with yourself about your
emotions
and communicate that effectively and
appropriately to your kids
wow that's fantastic somebody write that
down i wasn't writing that down
yeah i'm going to write that i guess
i'll come back and listen to it yeah
when are you gonna write your book dr
alfie i'm working on it you wouldn't
believe tuesday's on my writing day i'm
working on it i promise you
oh fantastic name something that
most people like but that you can't
stand my answer is the office
hey but you're i mean your answer
oh uh 24-hour cable news all my
girlfriends like it and i
yeah it drives me nuts and finally what
is your life's big
question
how do i maintain peace in the midst of
chaos
dr alfie breeland noble um this
was such an incredible privilege to have
this conversation with you i got so much
out of it
uh thank you i uh i feel enlightened and
nobled and what was it
embrace encourage enlightenment i feel
embraced encouraged and enlightened
so thank you so much for joining us on
metaphysical milkshake
thank you for having me it's been an
absolute honor and a pleasure
wow that was amazing uh sign me up uh
get me a ticket i'm first in line for
embrace enlighten encourage the dr alfie
story
incredible hard-hitting um and
depressing um angst ridden discussion
but
gosh she she provided so much hope but
this is
all again about are the kids all right
now
reza as the father of seven children or
was it 17 i can't remember
some of this stuff had to have really
landed for you as a dad
um you're practically raising an entire
generation of humans
yeah that's the plan but in all
seriousness did what landed for you
what resonated when she was talking
about how
the kids who seem to get through
the sort of inevitable mental health
trauma
of childhood right that it's like don't
worry about
trying to keep that from happening
instead figure out how to ameliorate it
and to point it in the right direction
and when she was talking about how it's
about
having purpose like having help your
child
find their purpose it just made
so much sense because like i this we've
talked about this before like
i knew what i wanted to do with my life
i i mean i don't remember when i didn't
know i did i don't remember a time in
which i wanted to be
anything else except the thing that i am
today
um and i think that that helped me a lot
in a way that i look at my
sisters i'm going to bag on my sisters
for a little bit
who had the same experience that i did
growing up
the same hardships the same traumas but
who have had a
far more difficult time of it
you know as as adults than i did and i
think
going back to what dr alfie said what
was the difference between the two of us
i think the difference between two of us
is that or the three of us i have two
sisters
sometimes i forget um is that i
knew what my purpose was and that kind
of kept me going so it's like
that's some good advice you know for
parents
it reminds me of this quote uh that
oprah
always tosses around she says it's her
favorite quote and i just love it too
it's reverend harold thurman who says
don't ask what the world needs uh find
what makes you come alive and do that
because what the world needs
is people who have come alive yeah
was there anything else besides find
your purpose to your to your bevy of
kids
well in the in the connection part you
know i think is
is something i'm i'm actually really
curious you know we talked about how
uh the pandemic has done good and bad
things
mostly bad but some good things and
in my family it's it's been really kind
of wonderful and i
in all honesty i'm sort of dreading the
idea that they're going to be going
back to school full-time soon and and
they'll be like an eight-hour day
which i don't have access to them and
um and that disconnection there so i
think i'm a little bit
nervous about that but the idea that
maintaining that connection is
so important to the mental health of
young people not just if you're a dad or
a mom or whatever
but also just thinking about what can
what can we do to foster positive mental
health
for this generation it's maintaining
their
connectivity right and yeah oh and i
loved it i loved that she was like
connectivity on their terms
you know instead of on your terms it's
it's right it's so awesome what's
comfortable for them
exactly yeah yeah it's positive for them
the thing that
that really struck home for me too and
i've done a little bit of but i need to
do more of as a dad is
share my failures
share my struggles share my mental
health issues
you know if i'm struggling with anxiety
share that with my 16 year old
destigmatize mental health by having
real conversations with young people
about
your personal experience with it yeah um
i think that is
really super important because as you
know as children of the 70s and 80s
our parents didn't share that stuff with
us hell
no they wouldn't even say if they my dad
would
obviously be in a despondent depression
for weeks and be like how's it going dad
fine no really how are you quiet
that was that was the discussion with
him real men don't talk about feelings
and it would have really helped it would
have really helped for him to say like
you know
son i just feel lost right now i don't
even know why
sometimes i really struggle with
depression you may have it too
someday and here's what helps me
something like that something is that
something you feel comfortable talking
to your son about like is that a
conversation that you could imagine
having or is it one that you have had
i've had micro versions of that but i'm
i'm happy to
go all in listen the stakes are really
high okay
and what this generation is facing is uh
incredibly daunting so they need all the
help they can get and if that means me
like really making myself vulnerable
with my kid
um yeah sure let's do it wow dr alfie
like not only was that fascinating
but you you made us better dads wow you
know yes we're getting paid
a little bit for this podcast but we are
getting paid in
a wealth of riches of wisdom yes and
that is very important
thanks cast media not as important as
you know money but still
very yeah very almost important for the
reason almost that we're doing this
thank you dr alfie for
diving so deep with us
all right metaphysical fans uh we want
to do something that's fast become
our favorite part of these episodes
where
we get to respond to listener voicemails
people out there who've pondered some of
the life's big questions that we've been
asking on this
show if you want to be someone that we
bring
on to this program if you want to join
me and reign
on the pod it's very easy to do this all
you have to do
is leave a rating and a review on apple
podcast telling us what your life's big
question is take a screenshot of it tag
us
on instagram at metaphysicalmilkshake
metaphysical milkshake
and if we love your comment or your
question
uh we will invite you on the show and
you can come and chat with us
speaking of which we got an incredible
uh connection with this dude
dante from detroit um he left us an
incredible question
and uh uh on a voicemail and so we
purchased a special voice recognition
software
to track him down hired anthony pelicano
whatever it took
um and after six months we finally
located him
here's dante let's hear his thoughts
are the kids all right i'd say so
i think today's youth are tooled with a
worldview
and an access to a worldview
that past generations just did did not
have
and it's it's allowing kids today
just the ability to be more empathetic
just be by being able to see
and hear and hear from and hear about
people all around the world just like
themselves
it's it's allowing today's youth to be
able to
relate to people that they'll never come
into contact with
and it's just expanding world view from
such a young age
it's impossible to hide from
because it's at your fingertips
but there's no such thing as as a
faceless enemy anymore i think it's
really going to help
as the world grows our youth are going
to lead the way
in don't want to get too wishy-washy
but empathy just leads to peace if
there's no faceless enemy
and you can relate to who they want you
to fight against
it's going to be lead to peace that's
fantastic and i love that empathy
leads to peace and this a younger
generation is armed with the tools
that humanity needs we have brought him
on board ladies and gentlemen please
welcome
via speak pipe our new friend
and metaphysical milkshaker dante
dante hello
hello retha hello rayne thanks for
having me
uh i love your thoughts so first thing
is what are these tools that today's
youth have that previous generations
didn't have uh well
it's unique to the younger generation
obviously
the internet which um compared
to how old uh the world is
is quite new and especially this younger
generation
even i'm of a little older generation i
grew up
well it was in its early stages but the
youth
have cellular phones with the internet
right at their fingertips from such an
early age this access to
uh vast knowledge you're very hopeful
here and you're very positive where did
this attitude of yours
come from um and how can you be so
hopeful
and especially uh putting the internet
front and center as
as a tool of positivity for today's
youth
uh suicide rates have uh gone up by
33 in the last uh seven years
how how do you answer uh i i don't know
i wouldn't
know too much about um those rates but
uh the the internet um along with
allowing us to connect with with people
around the world um
and this knowledge it forces us to take
things head on
there's really no no hiding things
anymore
um even uh looking back
at the golden ages and uh
the the the pros about past recent
generations in the 80s and 90s looking
at
the positives there under this new light
and all this
new information that we have and that
we're able to reevaluate
and see things actually as they are it
forces us to take them
head on and i and i don't know how you
can't be positive
with that um it could be seen a as a
negative
because there is a lot there are a lot
of challenges
um new challenges
pres very pressing challenges but i
think it's
um we have the tools and the younger
generation that's the tools
to take them on can uh dante just real
quick just uh take off the fake beard
[Laughter]
real beard covered beard so dante's
making actually
a a fairly salient point here one that's
made
a lot right it goes back to something
that adam grant told us like way back
and
salient means it's got salt in it yeah
that's right something very
salty um okay and adam grant's point
when we were talking about how do you
change someone's mind
was well facts don't change people's
minds
relationships um change people's minds
so
dante's making this argument that i've
heard a million times that i've made a
million times which is that
the more you know people of another
race or religion or ethnicity or
political view or whatever and i mean
know them like know them as people not
like know their views or whatever
um the less likely you are
to villainize or demonize um those
people
and it sort of expands your region i i a
hundred percent
believe that this is true i've seen it
in my own life
i 100 believe it's true the the
issue and i think this is what reign was
getting at dante is that
that tends to butt up against this kind
of
impulse that we have towards tribalism
right
like i remember see you grew up with the
internet rain and i remember when there
wasn't an internet and then there was an
internet and people were like oh my god
this thing is going to change the world
like people are going to have access to
knowledge and information from all
around the world like
the whole world is going to be open to
everyone and instead all it did was just
shrink the world down even smaller so
that you
never ever had to leave your bubble if
you didn't want to
so i hear you i mean i i personally
think that
the long arc of history as it is called
is is moving us
towards your view that kids are going to
be all right that
you know that there are more people who
are using
these new tools to expand their
perspective than there
are those who are you know contracting
i agree with you uh i just think that
maybe it's gonna
be a little bit harder and take a little
bit longer right
um you mentioned uh uh
it you you find this you can relate to
people
when you can really know them and
i wonder how how do you really know
someone
um i think um a very new tool
uh tick-tock uh something like that
allows you to see these little moments
in in people's lives which uh is that
how you uh
perhaps that's how you get to know
someone you see the smaller moments
for those of you who are only listening
because right now rain is doing a tick
tock dance
and you know what you know what ray i
feel like i really know you
i'm embarrassed by you totally
embarrassed by you but i but i feel like
i know you
in a way what this conversation has done
for me is i need to
um i need to reassess
my take on the internet because
something that you said dante is really
right on which is like
the cat's out of the bag we can never go
back we can never go back to 1996 and
one of the things that the internet has
done
is it has created it more of a world
community
we see people on social media
and on reddit on message boards they're
communicating with people from
pakistan and iceland and mongolia you
know it's not just
people from your neighborhood so we're
kind of seeing these world communities
k-pop fans have done incredible
political activism and they're not just
koreans k-pop fans are all over the
world
i know reza is a huge k-pop fan so huge
um
i'm going to reassess this i'm going to
try and take in your view there dante
that the kids are all right
due to the incredible unifying positive
force
of the internet i'm going to try and sit
with that dante
you're opening my mind that is a
difficult thing to do thank you so much
for coming on board metaphysical
milkshake give it up everyone for dante
thanks dante thanks so much
thank you so much everyone for listening
you want more of life's big questions
find us on social
at reza aslan and at rayne wilson and at
metaphysical milkshake let us know your
life's big
questions we just might explore them on
a future episode and please please
please remember to
follow rate and review metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcast
or wherever else you listen to podcasts
that's actually very important listeners
because
that helps with the algorithms that
control everything
you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
and you can watch us
have these conversations if that's what
turns you on
all right thanks everyone see you next
week
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan
and colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner it is edited by
tyler newbold and audio mixed by justin
kyle
original music is composed by jeff tang
so i was a kid who loved surfing my
favorite band in the world is youtube
i'm a black girl grew up in the 80s oh
no black people doing surfing back then
we're listening to you too frankly oh my
god bono
and the guys oh my god i just i just i'm
obsessed with them so anyway
we're gonna make you an honorary white
you
dude